attention pas d' insulte gratuite chez
moi quand je parle de phrases de connard
je parle de phrases qui trahissent de la
prétention ou de l'égoïsme voilà une
phrase de connard que certains mecs
aiment bien dire quand ils viennent de
se réveiller
ah désolé moi tant que j'ai pas eu mon
café je peux rien faire heureusement que
les mecs qui disent ça se retrouve pas
dans une situation d'urgence a désolé
moi de temps que j'ai pas eu mon café je
peux rien faire ça tombe bien
tenez à l'espresso noir sans sucre merci
bonne journée
il ya une bonne phrase de connard aussi
c'est celle ci ouais je te parle mal
mais ça va c'est bon j'ai pas du matin
comme si cette phrase suffisait à
excuser des paroles ou des actes hyper
agressif
vous êtes responsable de l'un des plus
gros génocide de l'histoire de
l'humanité vous avez quoi dire pour
votre défense raison que moi je suis pas
du matin très vite on fait des conneries
quoi bon bah ça va alors dans le même
genre pour se justifier d'avoir mal
parler à quelqu'un certains mecs disent
bah ouais désolé si j'ai fait un
scandale à table si ta mère à chialer
si le peacemaker de tonka lâcher mais
c'est comme ça je suis un mec entier
ouais t'es un connard entier quoi une
bonne phrase de connard égoïste
commentant malheureusement trop souvent
pas de façon moi je n'ai pas d'argent
sdf parce que si je redonne de l'argent
avec ils vont acheter de l'alcool
donc non plus cette phrase débile le
pauvre sdf qui vit dehors à -2 degrés en
hiver voyage et ce qu'il peut pour tenir
les mecs qui sortent cette phrase espère
quoi que le sdf il arrive au supermarché
etc avec leur argent il va acheter ça
alors je vais prendre un petit sirop de
papaye bio sans gluten est une clé usb
32 gigas c'est possible compatible avec
mon macbook pro
5ce une phrase de connards qui veut bien
montrer qu'il a du caractère
moi je m'énerve pas souvent mais je peux
te dire quand on me cherche on me trouve
une évidence tout le monde quand on
cherche s'énerve au bout d'un moment ça
peut jamais être l' inverse
moi je suis un gros vénère un mec vénère
de ouf ton temps mais quand on cherche
là je peux te dire là je deviens cool la
jupe est invité à faire un mini golf
moi je suis un cas un peu spécial parce
que j'ai un visage de mec gentil c'est à
dire que moi quand je m'énerve
les gens n'ont pas peur chloé s'est
amusé et a même pas range ta chambre
la phrase de connard la plus universelle
c'est celle-là je suis pas raciste mais
une phrase qui commence par je suis pas
raciste mais ne pourra jamais bien se
finir le pourra jamais se finir par un
truc intelligent c'est sûr je suis pas
raciste mais je pense que tous les
hommes naissent libres et égaux en
droits impossible voilà voilà la phrase
de caunes ardentes hipster qui veut
faire son malin en parlant de cinéma
django ouais bon c'est un peu quand un
qui fait du tarantino quoi cette phrase
n'existe que pour sa pt c'est sûr que
pour montrer qu'on a un avis un peu
différent des autres
en parlant d'un génie connu que tout le
monde aime bien ça marche pas avec un
mec que les gens aiment pas au genre et
un méchant un pédophile ouais bon c'est
un peu marque qui fait du trou quoi
parmi les phrases de connard il ya les
mecs qui se décrivent en mots clés pas
de façon moi je suis très grands vins je
suis très brunch entre amis bon je suis
très france inter je suis très david
lynch 1 je suis très très très chiant
aussi
ouais je suis très chiant si bon je suis
très vinyles de jazz
je suis très double peiné ouais ça c'est
un truc que j'aime je suis très apprécié
ma vidéo tu peut la partager
tout abonné à ma chaîne youtube attends
je peux pas m'abonner temps que j'ai
passé mon cap et en plus moi j'ai pas du
matin
maintien d'un café tabbone est
maintenant d'accord je m'abonne mais
c'est vraiment norman qui fait du norman
fait des vidéos quoi
j'en profite pour vous dire un très très
gros merci parce que mon spectacle
norman sur scène est plein à craquer à
paris ça y est la cigale 20 dates
complètes merci beaucoup
j'ai donc ouvert deux mois
supplémentaires au théâtre de bobino à
paris j'ai hâte de vous y voir j'adore
le concept ma nouvelle caisse
le kinder surprise de mes rêves ouais
oh [ __ ]